ma petite sœur elle a 15 ans de plus que
toi
mais c'est tout le temps
une attention au passage d'un train
éloignez-vous de la bordure du quai
plus dans le second degré je suis le
premier à m'avoir et je suis aussi en
train de faire des trucs pour
commander malgré la différence la
première fois
et
alors
est-ce que tu vas prendre la
testostérone est-ce que tu complexe par
rapport à ta voix est-ce que tu peux
faire une voix grave est-ce que tu
comptes faire une opération pour changer
de voix
donc ça c'est classique que j'ai tous
les jours la tête à Karim la voix à
Carine c'est là
parce que franchement c'est drôle
[Musique]
pourquoi pas mais j'aimerais bien savoir
je sais pas est-ce que tu saurais
expliquer pourquoi tu veux pas que je
peux pas y répondre c'est que je n'ai
pas la réponse à la question il faudra
voir un spécialiste
spécialiste en fait c'est juste
ou pas
dans 50 mètres tourner à gauche
je force sur ma voix du coup j'ai mal à
la gorge mais comme tout le monde peut
faire une voix plus aiguë plus grave
c'est exactement la même chose mais du
coup la plupart de référence avec ma
voix parce que demain je vais faire
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est Monsieur Madame
[Musique]
adresse mail mon numéro de téléphone
bref je me suis justifiée non ça sera
pas possible parce que vous n'êtes pas
monsieur vous faites passer pour lui
[Musique]
c'est mon voisin
du matin
[Musique]